vous le savez jacques chirac c'est lui
qui m'a donné ma chance c'est lui qui a
semé en moi cette petite graine qui a
germé
de la politique la politique est devenue
ma passion la passion du vie cette
passion de servir les français cette
passion qu'il avait au coeur
s'il ya un homme qui n'a jamais transigé
avec les extrêmes
c'est bien jacques chine
jacques chirac c'était l'amour de la
fosse lui il ne faisait pas la
différence entre paris et la corrèze
entre les vives et la ruralité il
n'était pas l'homme des métropoles
contre la ruralité il aidé l'homme de
toute la france jamet avec jacques
chirac il n'aurait eu des gilet jaune
et puis jacques chirac c'était l'amour
des français où il n'a pas eu besoin de
cinq ans demande à tous apprendre à
aimer les français lui les émet depuis
toujours est il les respecte et
jamais avec jacques chirac on aurait
entendu dire que certains français ne
sont rien jamais on aurait entendu vieil
homme qui voulait emmerder certains
[Musique]
et puis jacques chirac c'était aussi une
certaine vision du monde c'était une
parole forte porte est porté en afrique
aujourd'hui la france n'a jamais été
aussi impopulaire qui portait en orient
qui refusaient la guerre en irak qui
tenait tête aux etats-unis alliés mais
pas avant
alors oui sous jacques chirac la france
forte et puissante et nous devons
retrouver cette force et cette puissance
vive la république vive la france